foreign
[Music]
well hey everybody look we're both in
the frame this time holy crap like it's
literally like a minute before the show
started something
wet in my eye and I can't yeah get it
out so Pookie's trying to dig through
the side of Book don't do it puke that's
a good book
that looks like a new book what is she
trying to do that Pokey knock it off as
soon as the show starts she starts
acting up yeah because she looks just
stop pushing on spots
she's mad she doesn't want to start
doing the show yeah she's like you guys
what what are you why don't you talk to
me
uh so hey hey everybody uh Hugo says
happy goth day everyone yeah is it World
goth day I thought it was yesterday but
I don't remember I just saw some people
posting it better on Facebook I'm goth
every day so yeah
so I don't worry too much about it
uh but yeah so it's Monday and we're
talking about a haunting making our way
slowly through season five yeah
this is a good one yeah this was
actually a good episode yeah in in the
early Seasons they always had some about
haunted bars or restaurants and a lot of
those I thought were some of the weaker
episodes of their early seasons
but in season five this one is actually
a pretty strong episode I like it you
know uh
they actually just describe some
pretty strange phenomenon and there are
a lot of witnesses and they actually
show the witness give test Witnesses
give testimonies people that worked at
the uh restaurant it's a restaurant bar
I guess yeah it seemed like a restaurant
with a bar in it yeah so that type of
thing weird [__] happening throwing
objects and being watched and
psychics get involved in [__] portals
and [__] a lot to think well you know
what you know when you call a psychic
they're always going to get some portals
they're gonna some mirror portals
involved yeah it's because mirrors are
in every [__] structure they're
coming out of this yeah obviously
just like a person comes through a door
yeah all the ghosties come through yeah
the mirror through a mirror with yeah
that's
that's just psychics trying to find a
[__]
reason an angle yeah yeah well not
saying that it's not a real case it's
just saying
psychics and mediums and [__]
come in here and sell a narrative
uh yeah for sure uh murder Hornet said
an episode that doesn't have from the
grave in the title yeah this one is just
called The Uninvited which
I have to say that's also a really
generic title and it doesn't have [__]
all to do with anything in the story but
you know what else is new like none of
them do really
I don't know why they didn't call it
because usually usually if they have one
that's set in a bar or restaurant or
something it'll be like you know like
the haunting of the wheat Chief in or
whatever because that was that one that
we did so they'll usually name it after
the place
but they didn't this time it's just
called The Uninvited and like I said it
doesn't have anything to do with the
haunting so I don't know why they called
it that but whatever it was just one of
the just in in the little
uh you know uh what do you call it where
they just kind of like pick names out of
a hat it's just like a random title
generator so yes this is season five
episode eight and I remembered this one
but I didn't remember this one being
like a really good I think this is one
of the strongest episodes of season five
for sure even though like you said
usually the one set in bars like in the
earlier
uh Seasons we're usually not quite as
good as like the haunted house ones but
this one's actually pretty good
so uh so yeah so the cold open on this
one like the little Flash Forward that
they kept doing
uh starting in season five uh showed
somebody getting strangled with a
necklace that was like pulling itself up
by itself and uh you know strangling the
person so that was kind of like your
little teaser opening there
and then they jump ahead well no they
jump behind because they go two years
earlier
so apparently all of these events
started to happen in I believe it was
2007 that's what I wrote down anyway
um and we got a married couple Jason and
Lynn Ryder
now this happened I I neglected to write
down the name of the town but for sure
it was Connecticut somewhere I just
don't remember what the name of the town
was because I was trying to write it too
fast and I didn't write it down
so apparently Jason the hubby he buys
this kind of local hangout spot like
this restaurant bar that's called mori's
and they said this is pretty much like
one of the iconic you know bars in town
where like everybody goes and everybody
hangs out they're like it's kind of like
the cheers of whatever this town is you
know what I mean and I guess that Jason
and Lynn had you know had some of their
dates there and all this other kind of
stuff and it talked about oh one of
these days we should buy a restaurant or
buy this place or whatever so Jason
actually like surprises her by buying
this restaurant which I don't know if
that's the kind of surprise I'd be like
real happy about you know what I'm
saying yeah because that seems like a
large investment and that's going to be
a large time investment because
obviously running a bar in a restaurant
is very very time consuming and very
very expensive and very very stressful
you guys know what you're doing and you
got to know what you're doing which I
don't think these people did initially
uh they seem to get their [__] together
but they seem to be like one of those
people which you see a lot of like
Kitchen Nightmares and stuff where it's
just like well I just always wanted to
run a restaurant like I can't cook and I
never worked in a restaurant or how hard
how hard could it be I just thought it'd
be a neat idea yeah and then they get
there and they're like oh my God this
sucks it's so hard I don't even know how
to hire a a good Chef or a cook
you know it wouldn't know a good one
from a bad one yeah there are no proper
procedures or practices nothing you know
no food storage so you know yeah dumb
yeah dumb I mean why would you spend
that much money yeah and like running a
restaurant is basically a 24 7
proposition you're gonna be there all
the [__] time can't run front of
house they don't know how to hire a
person who can run in front of house
they don't know they don't even know
what to look for yeah you can't just run
a restaurant
no it's not like I mean running any
business is the ground yeah running any
business is difficult but running a
restaurant in a bar is particularly
difficult it is one of the most
difficult businesses and I'm gonna say
this I know both of these subjects and
have personal experiences in them you'd
be much more likely to be able to
successfully fly and land a Cessna
Aircraft then you would successfully
manage a restaurant without any training
right
yeah you're gonna [__] crash it it's
gonna be a [__] show yeah you'd be it
might be much better you'd be have a
much better chance of Landing in an
airplane
why do you think that there are so many
shows about like [__] Gordon Ramsay
has like five bajillion different shows
about that and then there's also a bunch
of other people that have that shoes
don't they have like Bar Rescue and all
those other kind of shows too because
people buy this [__] they think it's
like a cool idea and then they're like
oh wait it's actually hard work [__]
that yeah at least an airplane is a
machine and it's predictable restaurants
are not predictable they're not machines
a lot of us just feel and staff and if
you don't know what you're doing you're
gonna get [__] thank you murder Hornet
giving us a Super Chat thank you bud for
Tom's Trend fund
don't encourage him done with Tran
we got he's got other stuff but yeah
we're not we're not doing that anymore
no NPP we're not doing that anywhere so
yeah so Jason's like hey surprise uh
Lynn I bought this restaurant remember
how we were talking about that and she's
like oh uh great you know what I mean I
guess she was like pretty jazzed about
it so they actually renamed the
restaurant after themselves they name it
Riders um and I think it's called Riders
on Main or whatever the [__] the name of
the street was I couldn't really see it
so uh the next thing that the narrator
said was Lynn and Jason find out that
running a bar is more challenging than
they expected and I was like yeah no
[__] you think it is very challenging
now so aside from all of the regular
just everyday challenges that you would
have running a restaurant bar obviously
they're also having a couple little uh
weird things happen from the beginning
uh the first thing that they said notice
that they noticed a lot was uh shot
glasses in particular like kept
disappearing like Lynn would order a
case of them and then she's like you
know a few days later we'd be down to
like [__] six shot glasses and I
couldn't figure out where the [__] they
were all going it's like you know are
people stealing them or you know are the
employees breaking them and not telling
me or what the hell is happening uh so
yeah so they all start disappearing and
also Lynn said that her keys started
disappearing she's like that happened
pretty much every day she's like she
would just put the keys down and you'd
turn around and they'd be gone and like
they would spend like an hour looking
for them and then finally they would
find him and she's like and that
happened like pretty much every day too
so uh Lynn has been coming in early like
every morning like working on the
paperwork and all that kind of stuff
like you know before everybody else gets
there so she can have some peace and
quiet
and she didn't have a problem at first
but then one particular morning
she hears somebody like she's in the
back room and she hears somebody it
sounds like somebody's out in the
restaurant
even though nobody's there like it's all
locked up and everything like that it
sounds like somebody's kind of like
scraping around out there and she's like
what the [__] and then she hears
somebody
say her name
and she's like and they didn't just say
her name like hey Lynn they said her
first name and her middle name they said
she said Lynn Marie which really freaked
her out and I actually really liked the
the creepy effect they did on The Voice
I couldn't figure out like what effect
they were putting on it it almost
sounded like a weird metallic kind of
[__] and I don't know if that's really
what it sounded like but that's what
they did in the show and I thought it
was like really creepy
but yeah so she heard a voice saying
like Lynn Marie like right she said it
sounded like somebody yelling for her
from that out from inset from in the
restaurant you know what I mean like it
was her husband or her dad or so because
her dad works there too and she's like
but obviously nobody was there but
that's what she thought it was and she
said it was super freaky
so
um so she tells Jason about this but
like most of the dudes in a haunting
history he's just like oh you're just
tired you're imagining things you know
what I mean yeah I've been so tired that
I
heard ghosts saying my name not but you
know what I mean
so a few days after that
is Super Bowl Sunday and obviously this
is a restaurant bar so they're gonna
have like a big party for that
so Lynn is down in the stock room I
guess which is it looked like she said
it kept saying basement so I guess like
the stockroom is out in the basement
and she said while she was down there
she felt somebody tapping her on the
shoulder like from behind as she said
that tapped her once and she like turned
around like what the like because she
thought somebody was there and then
tapped and then it tapped again like
much harder like it was trying to get
her attention you know what I mean but
obviously nobody was there like she goes
and there were other people like in the
bar but they were all upstairs so she
like went up and was like Hey did
somebody just come down there and
they're like no you know it's whatever
so over the next few weeks apparently
Lynn said a whole bunch of other like
weird [__] would happen to her like that
like while she was around the thing but
nobody else was experienced anything at
first and so she's like everybody was
basically just like making fun of her
about it I'm like well that's nice you
know they were just like oh did your
ghost do that or her you know what I
mean and I'm like yeah she was probably
feeling like man [__] you [__]
you know what I'm saying it's like [__]
scary
but then it so happens that like I said
her dad helps them run the place right
because that was her dad right that
older dude
I think yeah yeah okay I'm answering a
question oh well I'm asking you a
question too what was the question again
never mind so
um so yeah so the dad is there
and he's taking some beer bottle like he
has like cases of beer bottles and he's
taking them down to the store room
because I guess they came in like a
shipment or whatever and when he comes
back up he said that there were beer
bottles just like spread out like all
over the floor and he's like and I could
not for the life of me like figure out
how that had happened because it's like
I just went down the stairs there was
nobody else in the bar but me and I came
up and there was just like beer balls
all over the floor and they'd all
previously been in the boxes so at this
point he's like huh well that's pretty
weird and then uh the next day he's
there again like by himself I'm
presuming in the morning
and he's going to stock the beer cooler
and the door shuts behind him while he's
in the cooler and traps him in there
even though nobody else is in the place
now like I said
um he basically because we were saying
well obviously if you have like a
walk-in freezer like in your restaurant
you can't get locked in there that you
know that it doesn't do that
so I'm assuming that they're saying that
it was like a paranormal type of [__]
like it you know like it locked or
something was holding it shut or
something like that because he said that
he couldn't get it open that was a weird
thing it wasn't much detail though about
that event right
I mean
normally in any modern structure you
can't
be locked inside of a cooler
yeah I mean that would be that can't
happen right that would be really dumb
if they made it because I mean you can
go in the cool like the door [__]
Shots by itself all the time you know
yeah
yeah there should be they open on both
sides and I don't think they're lockable
yeah that didn't happen anymore yeah I
don't really see why it would have to be
lockable that's the thing no like it's
not like it's in Fort Knox or anything
like that it's just frozen food in there
like you know
yeah well in a freezer out for sure they
wouldn't they would make it so you
couldn't lock it yeah you'd lock you
could accidentally lock an employee in
there and it kills them right they can't
get out that's what I mean
so yeah because there's obviously where
somebody's in there you're closing down
for the night somebody went in there to
go do something and you don't think
there's anybody in there and you [__]
stick a damn pin through it to lock it
you know what I mean yeah and then walk
out not knowing that Joey was in there
poor Joey you know he tries to get out
and that's it he's dead
you left for the night you locked him in
a damn freezer [__] like that has
happened in the past yeah they made sure
that
last I heard maybe that's a state laws
but any any state I was in there was no
way to lock a freezer
and like I said there's really no reason
for you to have to well they would say
well is to keep you from stealing it man
it's not a human to steal it they broke
into the place trying to get the frozen
food they brought broke they bought they
brought bolt cutters with them right
they just cut the lock
and it's like so you'd rather like have
like the off chance that somebody's
gonna steal some frozen food you'd
rather like leave open the possibility
that somebody's gonna get trapped in
there and die yeah
that figures yeah and then if you go to
it if you go to like a 7-Eleven the
cooler the walk-in cooler the you know
where all the little soda cans are and
[__]
those can't lock any either but even if
they did you could just [__] pull the
damn soda out of the way crawl out
through the [__] doors the big glass
doors where they opened to get the soda
cans yeah there's so there's no way to
lock anybody into those things they they
make sure I was just thinking though of
that whole plot point in The Shining
yeah where Wendy locked him now that was
that wasn't the freezer that was like
the dry storage but the freezer had a
lock on it too did it not the dry
storage for sure had a lock because Jack
couldn't yeah the dry storage had it but
that was
back in those days they'd have that
probably
there'd be no reason no safety reason
where you couldn't lock it
but you might want to lock employees out
of it not in so they can't go in there
and steal your Beanie Weenies yeah [__]
like that but you know they also made it
so there's no way to lock a refrigerator
yeah because kids would go into
abandoned refrigerators and shut the
door behind them there's no way out
they'd [__] cooked to death in there
in a [__] summer heat
yeah that happened a few times I
remember hearing some horrible stories
about that yeah it kid went missing and
it [__] days later find him in dead
inside her [__] old bed in
refrigerator
didn't they make it a rule too that if
you were throwing out a refrigerator you
had to like take the door off yeah it
was back when those refrigerators were
around they're long gone now yeah they
don't have them like that yeah like a
lot of things
and nothing could lock right yeah yeah
and like I said there's really no reason
there's no reason to
that it needs to so uh so yeah so her
dad got locked in the in the thing in
the
cooler
now he gets out like I guess he
struggles in there for a while like oh
[__] I'm gonna [__] die in here but
it does he does get it open and then in
the interim like Lynn has got there and
she's like what the [__] happened she's
like man there was nobody here and
somebody [__] closed me in this
cooler this you know it's crazy and so
Lynn said he looks like really really
scared so he's like now finally like at
least her dad starts to believe her that
maybe there is like some pretty weird
[__] going on around here
so they talked to Lynn's mom about it
and she says well maybe you should go to
a psychic because you know that's their
answer for everything
so the first psychic comes because
there's like a whole succession of
Psychics I'm just telling you right now
like who come who trooped through this
place they each got their own little
story but uh so the first one comes in
and says uh there are two Spirits in
here that's what I'm sensing
and they're not happy with all the
changes that you made to the place I'm
presuming like the name change or
whatever else they did
um now the psychic now okay now
according to Lynn who was really on the
show
she said that this first psychic who
didn't I don't think the first psychic
actually came to the bar she went with
her mom to that psychic like a
storefront psychic and so and that woman
said
um oh you own a bar don't you and she
said yeah she's like yeah there are a
couple Spirits in there and they don't
like that you've been [__] with the
stuff and like changing it from how it
was and then said oh has a bunch of
stuff gone missing and Lynn said yeah
and she's like oh well you'll find it
like under this particular box like in
the store room or like in the basement
or whatever and so Lynn was like holy
[__] so as soon as she gets back to the
restaurant allegedly she goes down to
the store room and moves this box that
um you know the psychic said it's a box
like in a particular corner or whatever
and she and moved it and that's where
all the missing shot glasses were like
on the floor like underneath this box
according to her so she's like the
psychic knew that without even going to
the bar because I don't think the first
psychic actually even came to the bar
she just like told her some [__] like in
her room little office or whatever
so they found all those
now Lynn says to Jason her husband
look the psychic said that the shot
glasses are going to be here and here
they are that's like pretty freaky and
Jason looks at her like she's she has
three heads and says you know don't go
telling the employees that kind of stuff
because they'll think you're a nutcase
that was the word he used nutcase yeah
he came off as a little bit of a jerk I
gotta say oh there's like the real guy
he did come off as like a little bit of
a jerk don't tell the employees that
they'll think you're right now
I'm like that's nice very very
supportive thank you Jason
so so yeah because he hasn't seen
anything yet but you know he'll get his
in a minute
so a week after that
um Lynn ends up hiring a bouncer whose
name is Tito
now apparently they didn't tell Tito
anything about the haunting and I guess
he didn't know anything about it
beforehand or so they all claimed
now he goes down to the basement but
he's like kind of creeped out by it he
said it was like just really oppressive
and like really cold down there
and at one point he goes down there like
to put some [__] away and something came
flying at him it was like a big roll of
uh register tape like came flying at him
and he's like at first he thought it was
Jason's just like [__] with him
because he was like kind of a prankster
so he was like just thought he threw it
but he wasn't there so he's like okay
that was pretty [__] weird so
register tape flying at him
the same night after the restaurant
closes
um Tito stays late like helping to clean
up and everything like that and he's in
I think he was in the kitchen right was
he in the kitchen of the store room I
can't really remember because I was like
looking up and down like while I was
writing when the when the balls yeah
yeah yeah yeah it was in the kitchen
near the uh yeah it looked like the kids
near the near the dish pit where they
wash the dishes yeah yeah yeah so yeah
like a bunch of bowls and pans and [__]
like just started hurling themselves at
him apparently so
as the ghost did not like Tito
apparently they just kept flinging [__]
[__] poor dude I know and he seemed
like a nice man you know what I mean
because the real guy was on there it was
a racist ghost it was maybe that's what
it was like black people I guess that's
what it was where's Connor goes race is
good yeah this is my house
he got all kind of [__] thrown at him so
yeah he's like all right nevermind we
never find out what happened to Tito
though even though like the real guy was
on the show like talking about yeah it
was credible yeah
something happened he he thought
somebody was messing with him and threw
a roll of dab register tape at him but
nobody threw it
and then some Bulls came flying down at
him yeah fell or it made it look like
they flew down at him they at least fell
off the top of the
shell yeah they might have dramatized
because it was pretty dramatic like in
the show it was like yeah it spoken
you know I believe him he saw that's
what he saw I don't know maybe somebody
did throw a roll of tape at him and
never fessed up but there's no way of
knowing maybe this [__] just fell I
don't know
Ben said ghost Ben said ghosts are very
big on being white
what the hell man and they wear sheets
yeah
so you know maybe maybe that's what it
is we figured it out we figured it out
we figured it out for you Tito
yeah that's why that's why the ghosts
are throwing [__] at you
so uh so yeah like I said I don't know
what happened to Tito after that I don't
know if he was like yeah [__] this place
and it's like left but I don't know
because I don't think they talked to him
again after that
later that night though so I'm assuming
this is like the middle of the night
because this is like way after the
restaurant a bar closes and you know
Lynn and Jason went home and are
sleeping
so uh the phone rings at the Ryder house
they're like alarm has gone off at the
restaurant
now Jason said this alarm this time the
alarm went off he's like this was the
third time this week like the alarm just
kept [__] going off and it's like
there was nobody in there like nobody
ever broke in but it just kept going off
and he's like this time
um the cops didn't even bother to show
up because they're just like man [__]
that it's just like you must be getting
some [__] in your alarm system because
we're not even bothering
so um Jason Goes though because it's his
restaurant
and he goes in there and he's like you
know it doesn't look like anybody broke
in or anything like that but when he's
going through the restaurant there's he
can see like um the the kind of swinging
door that goes like to the kitchen in
the back and he can see like light
underneath it and he's like in that
light underneath the crack of the the
crack in the bottom of the door he said
he saw
like three black Shadows like there were
people moving around in the kitchen
so of course he thinks oh some
[__] did break in after all so
he grabs a baseball bat
and he's like you know getting ready to
[__] throw down or whatever
so he kicks open the kitchen door but of
course nobody's in there like you know
so the Shadows he saw who knows what
that was
so he's like okay whatever so he goes
back home and then an hour later the
alarm goes off again and he said it went
off five times that night
now in the um reenactment they also
showed the Jukebox coming on by itself
but he didn't say that that you know
what I mean yeah but they did show it
and I think that happened later too
nobody mentioned that happening but they
did show it a couple of times in the
reenactment so I don't know if they just
said it on [__] that they edited out or
if they were just like making [__] up I
don't really know
and then a little while later because up
until this point I feel like people that
were like the patrons of the bar the
restaurant weren't really seeing
anything or weren't really experiencing
any of the stuff that like the employees
and stuff were seeing however there was
one point where they're like some guys
playing pool because they have like a
pool table in there and apparently the
cue ball like jumped up like in this
really weird way that didn't look like
it could do it naturally yeah although
we were watching that and I was like
well I don't really I mean it would have
to be like go up and Float like this
I've seen like people like Papa cue ball
like up over I've seen them [__] jump
them yeah you can do that yeah but um
but apparently this was weird enough
that everybody was like what the [__]
we're not playing pool anymore yeah and
the uh the management was like well we
need to fix this table it may not be
level type of deal they would try to
make an excuse for it yeah cause they
were trying to they didn't want to like
freak everybody out so obviously they
didn't want to lose their business they
didn't want people yeah
it's not 100 that was paranormal though
yeah I'm not sure that might have just
been somebody just might have hit it
just right with the queue and it went
flying because I've seen
I've seen people do that like trick
shots can do it right
that's what I mean murder Hornet said
Tom's head AKA cue ball that's right
um what oh who's talking oh murder
Hornet said my parents in Florida live
in the middle of the forest I helped
them clear out a spot for the cabin
split many along I helped build their
Log Cabin Lord it was awful in that
Florida heat I can imagine did you did
you build it in the summertime
how are you still alive I don't even
know how people work outside like I feel
so bad for people that work as roofers
and stuff down here holy [__] how can
they like not get heat stroke because
they're all South American I guess
they're used to it
well people used to be used to it here
too because I guess like all the white
guys are like yeah they're just like
you know people used to be tougher
because you know there was [__] here
before air conditioning they were
building houses here in the 1800s back
to the 1500 or 1600 I think 1500 there
were stuff going on here Spanish Empire
stuff that you know it's [__] hot
well yeah St Augustine was there in the
1500s yeah so you know some of that [__]
was yeah still is still standing there
people have gotten soft
they didn't know any better though
that's what I mean I don't even know if
it's so much that it's just like they
didn't know any different like it was
just you just had to put up with it and
I'm sure it sucked and I'm sure they
bitched about it you acclimated to stuff
though they didn't have air conditioning
yeah just when the summer came you
acclimated to well I mean you can
acclimate to anything it's just that
nowadays we don't really have never
really acclimation because you got air
conditioning right and it's like you get
used to that I don't [__] want to be
without air conditioning we lost air
conditioning at one time man and these
houses are [__] unlivable without air
conditioning God it's awful we were
trying we were had to [__] bathtub
filled with cold water we're getting in
there [__] trying to sleep on the
floor because we try to get as low as we
possibly could remember that yeah we get
in the middle of the night miserable and
[__] and getting in the cold bathtub to
cool off and then getting back up it was
[__] hot it was a [__]
yeah it feels like it feels like opening
Windows
it feels like a hot wet blanket sitting
on your face like you can't breathe
through it
can't really open the windows because
mosquitoes will come in and roaches and
yeah roaches snakes and
the Lord and you open the window
and it doesn't get any cooler it doesn't
make any difference yeah because there's
no Breeze as such it's just it just kind
of sits there the air just kind of sits
yeah it's like Vietnam it is it's it's
awful yeah it's awful and then two days
later the [__] whole house [__]
smells because the moisture has worked
its way into the dirt in the carpeting
yeah and yeah everything smelled like a
wet dog he smells like a wet dog
damn as soon as the air conditioner goes
comes back on about an hour later it's
all gone yeah and you're vacuuming well
like I said you really you have to have
air conditioning or everything will mold
yeah within seven days yeah you'll just
have mold all over everything well an
abandoned houses don't mold up
um
or at least they do eventually but yeah
it can happen depends
depends depends on the moisture level
it definitely mold on the outside of the
house oh yeah easy houses go green if
you don't [__]
pressure wash them every now and then
with bleach Camp guy said I hate
sweating in my tighty weighties you have
to keep it dry down there except for the
fungal consequences it's true you can't
go around with like a wet ass crotch you
just can't so yeah that's a problem that
you have in Florida I mean they they
have the term swamp ass for a reason
yeah you know what I mean it's yeah the
struggle is real it had the uh British
guy
he's a famous YouTuber named Carl
Benjamin he's known as a Sargon of akkad
and he brought his family down to
Orlando to go to [__] Disney World
and he's in the hotel and he opens up
the hotel balcony and looks down
to look at the area around Disney and
it's a swamp and he goes and he goes you
don't understand look at this [__]
because I didn't expect it to be like
this this is a swamp and it's yeah hot
as Satan's ass crack it says it is a
hundred percent humidity and at over 100
degrees Fahrenheit here he says it's
like being immersed in hot Steam and
being wrapped in plastic yeah yeah
that's exactly yeah on a hot summer
you're [__] he was astounded that's
why I don't even know why people bother
going in those [__] um like saunas
and stuff I'm like just go outside yeah
it feels exactly the same especially
right after a rain
go outside after a rain
man it stormed really bad today like my
whole entire my almost my whole entire
drive home yeah was like [__] rains
every day rains every day this time of
year
in the summer and into the Autumn yeah
like and we're not just talking like a
little drizzle either it's a downpour
yeah and you never can't tell and I ride
almost every day so I get wet yeah oh a
couple days it I made it home
uh before the rain hit uh but that last
time a couple days later
I was coming back from Starbucks
and I look up the road ahead of me I
just see a black wall a gray curtain
coming my way to I'm like oh [__] oh
here we go
it's like a wall of water
water and rain and even the cars in
front of me started to Swerve we started
we slowed down to about 20 miles an hour
15 miles an hour to just boom I was
sopping wet in about three seconds
on a motorcycle on that little Buell xb9
see I worry about that yeah well you can
just go off the road if it gets that bad
I know but it's no big deal I was
worried today because I didn't know if
you were out riding today and I was like
coming home and I was like holy crap
look at this [__] I could barely see and
I was in my [__] car well before I
actually leave they're all look in the
direction of the house and try to see if
I can see rain because it's only a few
miles it looked it looked light over
there so I I booked back okay but it was
coming yeah it eventually came here
the worst part today for me driving home
was like just the cars in front because
it was real windy too like it was real
windy so it kept the car in front of me
and I tried to stay back but it was like
blowing all the water like into like
into my windshield what's weird is it'll
be it was like it'll be 100 humidity 95
degrees
and then in a heartbeat you're hit with
a wall of cold water and it drops down
to about 60 degrees Fahrenheit
and then after it's over it gets like
even hotter yeah and it only does it for
about 15-20 minutes maybe an hour most
and then all of a sudden the Sun comes
out and it boils all that [__] water
off in your in a sauna it's it's
miserable yeah miserable
it'll get you
yeah I told you it's like even even in
the house like with the air conditioning
on like in the summertime like you get
out of the shower and you're just
instantly sweaty again yeah that's awful
yeah I can't stand it I can't stand the
weather going to be it's how it be it
bees that way here it does yeah yeah I'm
just saying if you don't like humidity
like don't even think about it because
you're gonna have a bad time I got used
to it
I it's weird because I was born here and
I'm really never have gotten used to it
you know Mississippi's even hotter
so it used to be when I was a kid not as
bad as it used to be but Tammy said you
really aren't selling Florida
telling people because I I think people
kind of think oh it's this vacation
paradise and everything like that I'm
like well it is I mean it is but it's
tropical yeah subtropical it's actually
subtract sub travel but I would call it
tropical and it's like I said it's a
swamp it's a swamp just keep that in
mind yeah if you don't like swampy if
you don't like swampy ass then
you're gonna have a bad time because
it's like that for a large portion of
the year because I lived in Brazil too
you could say that hum is on us or the
Amazon River Basin is tropical
Florida's worse much worse it's a lot
hotter
it's a lot hotter yeah a lot more
miserable
it might be subtropical but
during the rainy season in the summer
it's it's [__] miserable it is super
[__] hot
Tammy says I like my changing seasons
way too much even enjoy snow yeah that's
one thing I always kind of wish that
there were like season changes because
Florida doesn't really have seasons it
has two
cool and [__] hot
yeah and cool is like maybe a month
that's not that it seems that weird off
and on it's like five months and then
the rest of it is just like hot as [__]
like we're not going outside hot
I'm just holding up in the house in the
AC
it's not hot as [__] all the time during
so it's 80s 70s 80s high 70s for a
couple months and then it gets really
[__] hot and it goes back it's got
Seasons it's just got two hot and cold
there's just not a big distinction not a
big distinction yeah it's not kind of
like a delineation right and I would
in in in Korea they have a monsoon
season and I would call
Florida summer is also kind of like
monsoons yeah it is it just [__]
rains every [__] day like pretty much
every afternoon you're gonna have really
bad thunderstorms
mild flooding and stuff lightning
strikes and [__] yep
uh okay so where were we oh we were
talking about the the pool the cue ball
like popping up okay so that was kind of
the first thing that like weirded out
some of the patrons I guess
then there was this woman who was there
and she was in the bathroom and I guess
she was in there by herself and she goes
in the stall and you know does whatever
she needs to do and then comes out and I
guess there's there's all these big like
scratches on the wall suddenly that were
not there like prior to her going into
the stall so she wigs out so she goes
gets and gets Lynn she's like um I gotta
show you some [__] in here so they go in
there and so Lynn said at this point
more um customers and stuff were
starting to
get kind of freaked out and like ask her
about the disturbances and again she's
kind of like wary of losing business so
she's kind of like trying to blow them
off and be like or make a joke about it
or come up with like some lame
explanation or something because she
didn't want people which is weird
because they always kind of say that
it's like oh we didn't want nobody to
show up or anything I feel like if you
said nowadays hey my shit's haunted that
like
um everybody would want to come there
you would think like I I would lean into
it that'd be like a selling point
because there'd be a lot of people that
would be into that you know
I don't know but she thought that you
know people wouldn't come there because
they'd be like
scared or whatever and I guess people
were getting scared
so one day uh once in the summer
so Jason who is good at fixing stuff
around the bar he's like fixing a pipe
in the basement
and he said he felt this really really
intense uh like a cold draft and he's
like and it was a really hot day it was
like 90 degrees or something like that
and he said then he started seeing like
people like weird shadows like out of
the corner of his eye like he's like I'd
be you know doing whatever and he's like
and I'd see what I thought was a person
and like I look over there and they
there was nobody there you know what I
mean so he started to get like a little
freaked out about that
and then one morning uh Lynn hears that
really creepy voice calling her name
again like I said not just Lynn but it
said Lynn Marie like that was her first
name and her middle name
and then she kind of goes out to see if
somebody's out in the main restaurant
and apparently
she didn't really say that this happened
because this is very dramatic
but she goes out into the regular
restaurant and like all the doors
because there's like the kitchen door
and I guess like a bathroom door and
like some doors some other [__] I don't
know and it like all and they all
started like swinging back and forth
like by themselves
um and then the Jukebox comes on by
itself again
and so it seemed like real intense like
all of this Paranormal Activity was
going on and she's kind of like freaking
out and the only thing she did say was
that
she felt like she was trapped like in
the back corner of the restaurant so I'm
assuming that you know there was scary
[__] like going on in the other part of
the restaurant and she felt like she
couldn't go there and she also felt like
she said she felt like the um the air
felt really tight like he couldn't
breathe but I will note that I'm pretty
sure she didn't because I didn't write
it down that she did not say that the
doors were swinging back and forth and
the Jukebox came on by itself but they
did show that in the reenactment so I
don't know if that really happened or
not
so Lynn decides she's going to call in
yet another psychic who's like a friend
of hers who's like a clairvoyant or
whatever and This Woman's name is Karen
Hollis
now Karen Hollis shows up and she says
you know the same thing that they
usually say when they show up it's like
oh the air feels really heavy and it's
like it's really like it feels ice cold
in here and she said the first thing
that you thought when you came into the
place was that someone was
was thinking why are you here like you
know it felt like really like you were
really unwelcome
so Karen is the one that came up with
the whole oh you've got this old mirror
in I think it was in the store room or
the basement or whatever
um and this is where they're coming in
this is the portal or whatever they
didn't really go too much into that but
you know what I mean so we got a mirror
portal going and this is where the
ghosts are coming in
so a week after that Karen brings her
paranormal team in to do an
investigation
now one of the guys on the team like
looks into kind of the back story the
history behind this bar which is now
called Riders it was called Maury's uh
they said it was actually originally
when it was built it was built in the
1800s as two residences that were like
right next door to each other and then
at some point um you know the the wall
was torn out in between them and then it
was made into like various stores like
they said it was a feed store it was a
paint store bloody blah and then um you
know it eventually became mori's and
then they bought it now they thought
that there had been two deaths in there
in a fire that happened in 1976 but they
did not elaborate on this so I don't
know
how true any of that is but that was
something they were speculating about
so while Karen is down in the basement
trying to like suss out
what the what the ghost situation is
she said that she felt an entity over
her left shoulder
and while they were doing
um I guess she was doing or like
recording stuff or like asking questions
or like kind of like an EVP type
situation but she said and this wasn't
an EVP she said she heard it just like a
disembodied voice just like coming out
of the air she said she heard a voice
say I'm so weak
okay so I don't know if they recorded it
or not but she said she heard that and
so she apparently like asked the ghost
like what do you mean weak like
physically or emotionally and the ghost
said both so and that wasn't on
recording that was she said she just
heard it with her ears
so she says yeah you got at least two
entities in here
but one of them is the one that's
causing all the trouble the other one
seems like not really like doesn't talk
or doesn't want to communicate or
whatever
so they set up like a laser grid type
situation in the basement
and then one of the team when they were
when he was working on it like felt a
tap on the back of his head and then saw
the grid kind of move or like undulate
like something was walking through it
and then one of the other investigators
I think it was the same guy I don't
remember if it was the same guy or a
different guy on the team but I guess it
doesn't really matter but one of the
investigators said that something ran
through him and the analogy that he used
was like sand through a screen door like
a like a ghost ran through him like that
because he like I I guess he was over
doing something or other over in this
corner and he was like well you know
what I mean like he like hunched over
and they're like what the [__] happened
to you Earl or whatever the [__] his
name was and um I think it was Kurt
actually and uh yeah he was like oh
something just went through me you know
what I mean but like I said that's very
subjective you don't know if that
happened or not during that Mammoth
Mountain
incident that
I told Jenny about she wrote the book on
there were kind of like
instances where both me Lois and red
felt like something passed through you
but it was like a zone of cold went
through you but we were we were like
yeah I think it went through me but
there's no way of really knowing like I
said it's subjective it's invisible
yeah
it's not like a wind
because you feel wind on the skin
it's kind of like what he said kind of
like sand going through a screen they're
kind of like yeah it penetrated through
you
but you're like did I imagine that
because I'm scared you know you don't
know it's just
it's difficult it's difficult to tell
what was real you know when something
moved but some of the stuff was just
vague
visual effects and
sensory stuff
but like I said that's subjective yeah
that's the thing about it that's why I
can't really hang with a lot of those
ghost shows because a lot of the [__]
that happens on there it's like oh
something touched me I'm like how the
[__] do I know that yeah you're on TV
you could just be making it up or you
could just be imagining it I'm glad in
my case objects were moving because we
knew that the objects were moved right
you know yeah that's a little more
definitive we knew that those moves so
then oh just something touched me yeah
right we knew we weren't going crazy
yeah we're like we're like man that was
from downstairs had that get in this
room
it didn't pass us yeah we were standing
in the doorway how did it get in here
you know must have penetrated through
the matter or teleported the only way is
[__] but we don't understand much
about physics we think we do but more
I'm Listen to Somebody's size programs
like Event Horizon they'll have these
scientists on all these different
disciplines quantum mechanics and
[__] uh uh different kind of [__]
string theories and stuff they really
don't know what matter is or what space
is it's all it might you know realities
are a lot weirder than we than we think
it is you know
that's true we have explanations for it
that seem to work but there's there's
more to it than that they were saying
that AI eventually might figure it out
AI super computers would probably be
able to understand reality a little bit
better than us because it's going to be
able to look at the universe the whole
Cosmos the way it's working
and there's things we don't know about
dark matter and
what is the actual space made out of
that kind of stuff
strawberry jam we'll figure it out one
of these days
three-dimensional space may not seem to
be real because
of expansion you know
um so yeah so here's Karen again
and she decides she's gonna do a
clearing to get the ghost to cross over
and she's doing I've actually never I
don't think I've ever seen anybody do
this particular
um
thing before it's kind of like an EVP
session but she asks questions of the
ghosts and then she draws a card from
the Tarot deck and she just considers
that her answer yeah which seems a
little yeah
what's the word I'm looking for
lame
I don't trust psychics
some people swear by them but
like they had that German
parapsychologist he says you had to have
a trans medium before you could get to
anything a good one
before you could solve any of these
Poltergeist and ghost cases what was the
name of that guy you remember him as
German parapsychology he's dead now he
was old when I was young it was that um
roll yeah I think it's something I think
it might have been his name
but
mediums and psychics can spin Yarns too
you know what I mean you're dealing with
dealing with some you know it's it's
fallible
and some of them inside you can measure
and some of them might actually believe
their own [__] like some of them
might be like self-deluded yeah so I
don't trust that I believe only trust
things that can be measured yeah like I
said because that's also subjective they
could have all kind of feelings I can
have [__] feelings but that doesn't
mean that that has like any analog in
the real world you know what I mean and
and you know
you know there's an outside chance that
their feelings might be correct but
there's no way to prove that they're
correct right that's what I'm saying
yeah we're not like [__] on
everybody's feelings or anything like
that because obviously people's feelings
do turn out to be correct I'm just
saying that there's really no way to
measure that yeah
the Army believed in this kind of [__]
you know they had [__] project
Stargate where they were doing remote
viewing and some remote viewers could
actually
Target images
in one case it was some [__] typhoon
class submarines I didn't know that they
existed they didn't know those existed
in Russia but they described it they
could see it through this remote viewing
technique that they were using
later on it was confirmed that it was a
submarine
and it was a typhoon-class submarine
they didn't know about them
but here's the thing man it's hard
difficult to measure that
a satellite would be a lot better
satellite you get a picture of it you go
yeah it's there
a psychic dude describing it
there's a there's an element of it might
have been luck if you do enough
predictions right that's what I'm saying
you throw enough [__] at the wall some
of it was something that's gonna stick
yeah just by pure coincidence or law of
averages yeah and the way they were
remote viewing was different you know
what I mean it's not as I expected I
always expected maybe they would like go
into a trance and [__] go out of body
which that's happened to me before
you go out of body and you're in like
the what you would call I guess the
astral realm or the slightly outside the
physical then you'd maybe appear there
and see it that's not how they were
doing it
they were doing it by
kind of like
asking questions about something that
was unrelated and a person would make an
answer but the person doing the
questioning was actually asking about
something totally unrelated informing
an image or a static a description of
what they were asking so it was kind of
like double blind right the person who
was supposedly in the trance had no idea
of what
the person asking the questions was
trying to Target right
um that way uh the person supposedly
says it was like a way of kind of doing
random generation but they were the
subconscious of that person
was free from conscious thought so it
was able to describe it it was weird how
they were doing it was not a thing where
okay I see it it's not like that the
person never saw it they were just
answering a bunch of questions the other
guy's forming an image
through a bunch of pre-planned questions
like a questionnaire right and from that
he's going okay yes 300 you know 300
feet long it weighs this much it's got
[__] five tubes on it and the person
that supposedly saw it had no idea that
it was a submarine
yeah so it was like a double blind
yeah I mean I guess that's one way to do
it I mean at least they were trying to
uh you know forest all the possibility
that you know you were suggesting
something to somebody or something
because like I said that's a really
difficult yeah test to set up because so
much of it is like I said subjective
yeah and the way the Army was doing it
is that
it was totally random so the person
giving the results had no idea what what
they were really looking for
so he couldn't put his own conscious
suggestions into it right but that's
good that's what you're supposed to do
yeah
because you're you're trying to like you
know in scientific studies like that
you're always supposed to minimize the
possibility that anybody is suggesting
anything yeah yeah anything like that
you're not supposed to be influencing
right the outcome so they kind of had
that and evidence and in that system
the guys that were using it in the army
this is old now they they ended that
program it did exist it's not something
out of the science fiction
or what was it gonna say
oh uh they got it to where the person
who's supposedly in the trans viewing
could be anybody did they weren't any
kind of special psychic it was more like
they're just using a person as a vehicle
for random generation but somehow
that random those random answers I guess
you could say
going through this formula that would
end up forming
a description of a Target that they
wanted to see
and the person who has supposedly seen
it had no idea
weird
so there was no claims of any psychic
abilities in the person seeing it right
they're just making a decision yes or no
yes or no yes or no basically
crazy that is kind of crazy but that's
how they were doing it yeah
yeah is that anybody could be a remote
viewer with the system
because they don't know what they're
doing yeah they're like a random number
generator just winging it yeah well the
person is being used like a random
number generator basically right
yeah well like I said that's technically
if you're gonna do an experiment like
that that's
one of the better ways yeah
I used to know exactly how it was but
you know because it's been a long time
since I've read the book but that's just
how I remembered it
Camp guy brings up the Milgram
experiment did we ever do a show about
that no no that's it that's it yeah we
ought to do some [__] like that yeah the
one where they told the subject they
were sending electric shocks to another
subject yeah something like 80 of all
citizens would continue to give shocks
if instructed to do so by authority
figure continued to fatal levels yeah
yeah a lot of them would people are
obedient well I think that after it got
up until like where it started getting
really bad it's obviously um the
percentage started falling off somewhat
because you know people did start to
protest but yeah alarmingly like most
people actually did go along with it
like wait yeah way longer than they
should have on a related subject of that
of this I've been listening to this
audiobook that's on YouTube and I
encourage everybody to listen to it it
was written in the 50s by a guy from the
Netherlands named Juiced Juiced
j-o-o-s-t and I remember it was a it was
a medical doctor an MD and it's called
rape of the mind and he talks about how
so the Soviets and the Nazis and any
kind of like uh totalitarian governments
how they brainwash people it's about
brainwashing and how it works
[__] fascinating man because you see
it happen you see the United States
using the same techniques gotta frame
things through corporate media and
it's called rape of the mind and you can
you can listen to it for free on YouTube
I encourage everybody to see it but it's
kind of like the Milgram experiment they
say that people are basically
subservient that they'll believe what
they're told as long as it sounds
official they talk about the statistics
and everything and why they're doing it
and what kind of psychologies are
involved
and who falls for this and why it's
about guilt and shame and how you can
use that to get people to enslave
themselves it's really good and this is
written in the 50s so it's not clouded
by modern politics
it's just the technique of how it's done
so okay so where were you tarot cards so
yeah so she's basically asking questions
and like I said this just seemed really
dumb to me because she's like oh well do
you um do you want to go like crossover
or whatever she asked The Ghost and then
she turns over the card of like the sun
or something just like oh that means yes
and I was like does it okay I'll take
your word for it and then she turns over
the you know because they always have to
do one of the Sinister ones they didn't
pull the death card this time but they
did pull the hanged man
um so she's like oh well I heard that
somebody hanged themselves in this bar
I'm like if you know anything about
tarot cards the hangman doesn't even
mean that like it doesn't mean literally
a hanged man you know what I mean yeah
it sounds Sinister and [__] like that
but it represents they all represent
something else they're all symbolic yeah
so yeah but so they didn't even like
bring that up again like I said so I had
that Crowley tarot card set I got a set
sorry for that thing yeah yeah I had the
manual that went with it and everything
it was it was interesting and you could
ask your ask yourself questions and
start doing readings for yourself and
you could kind of feel that you oh I
could see what it's trying to tell me
but it's like horoscopes yeah yeah it's
just like horoscopes it's not it's not
real it's
it's just it's emotion well and I kind
of feel like most of the time if you're
Consulting tarot cards about a problem
that you're having for example well the
thing about it is that you I feel like
it on some Subterranean level you
already know the answer to your problem
um you just feel like you need like an
outside force to like confirm it man
I'll tell you what you're just you're
just basically do like you already know
the answer you're just massaging it yeah
I'm gonna tell you [__] a story though
this is some [__] cool [__]
in Boston there was a bar called The
Rathskeller it was a famous punk rock
clubs over near Fenway it's gone now
Sex Pistols played there but I think the
Clash actually played there downstairs
they had a dude who's a regular me and
Ty Tyrone was another guy
would hang out with this dude off and on
he was there almost all the time and he
was like Indian he was like from India
he was really good with like [__]
[__] like tarot and [__] uh astrology
and [__] and he would get drunk and
[__] tell a fortune for you
and that [__] was right
quite often one time I was trying to buy
a used motorcycle
I had the money and it was at a
dealership it was a [__] Bandit 400
they would want to it's giving it for a
song and for some reason they said yeah
the price is only like 600 bucks I had
the money this is well we can't come
back next week man I think we'll be
concealed to you I didn't know what the
problem was at the time I found out
later
that they kind of that was a trade-in
motorcycle on a deal that that
dealership did but there was a lien on
that motorcycle they didn't know so they
couldn't sell it
but I didn't know that at the time
so I asked him about this I says this
place won't sell me the motorcycle I
don't know what the [__] problem is
they keep telling me come back in a
couple days and he goes oh yeah that's
because Venus is in retrograde this and
that paperwork's all [__] up now
that'll never happen I said what do you
talk about that'll never happen he goes
yeah uh yeah and he's talking about
certain stars and he's like yeah that
won't happen a lot a lot of loans and
[__] this is a bad time to get a loan
never did get it I found out later that
yeah they had a lien on that motorcycle
they couldn't sell it
but it was weird you know what I mean
that he kind of predicted that there's
no way you'll get that even though I had
the money yeah
but I'm just saying you know we're in a
bar yeah we're in a bar but that dude
was really good about
he was like a Swami some people are
really really good job but the thing
about it is that to be good at that kind
of stuff like you have to be like a
magician like a cold reader exactly you
have to know about cold reading yeah and
you have to
um be able to read people like really
quickly yeah but I don't know how he
knew that the [__] title would be
locked up I didn't know I was just a man
well maybe he was just winging it like
just saying oh you know it's a bad time
to get alone yeah because of this star
and Richard he says no no no it's a bad
time right now Ben said maybe he placed
the lien on the bike
he was he was cool though he's like in
his 50s and had long hair he's real dark
skinned [__] women liked him and [__]
and uh if you give him a [__] picture
or that rascaler on tap bear you get
like a picture of that [__] for four but
give a picture and he'd sit there and
tell fortunes for you all [__] night
any question you'd ask you'd come up
with some [__] [__] and he would he
could word it the right way it was just
like
reading the [__]
horoscope you know how a horoscope kind
of fit anybody yeah he could word it so
it'd [__] real quick very
entertaining I forgot the guy's names I
haven't thought of that dude in a long
time that's back in the [__] 90s yeah
they all that's a that's a pretty common
thing they do like in critical thinking
classes and stuff like that is they
print out a bunch of um horoscopes and
they give them to everybody in the class
and say oh I printed out a personalized
horoscope for all you and I want you to
like Mark how
um how accurate it is and they said most
of the kids in the class will say oh my
God it's super accurate and then they
find out that they gave everybody the
same one yeah yeah yeah
he was good at it though man and he was
real entertaining at the [__] bar man
and that was that was his end with the
chicks
chicks would be sitting there talking to
him and he'd tell them [__] give him
[__] fortunes all [__] night
I don't know man if I'm in a bar and
like some dude starts talking to me
about like Venus being a retrograde and
stuff yeah yeah bye well his delivery
was really cool he had an accent I'm
like unless you got some good drugs or
something
and he wasn't asking for money okay he
wasn't asking for money he's just keep
you just kept getting him some beers and
he'd sit there and [__] telephone so
it's all [__] bad
will soothsay for beer
yeah so uh yeah so like we were saying
this whole hanged man thing they never
bring that up again like oh I heard
somebody was hanging to this I don't
know I was like like I said that's not
[__] literal that card
so Karen says just very casually I'm
gonna
um create a light for the spirits to
walk through she does not get into the
specifics of how she does this
um she's just very nonchalant about it
and I was just like wait what let how
okay what does that entail but she
doesn't tell anybody I'm just gonna make
a light for the spirit to watch remember
like it was the most natural thing in
the world I remember that dude's name
his name is Vijay
was an Indian guy named Vijay I mean is
this funny I remembered his name okay go
ahead
um I can't believe I remember that
dude's name yeah yeah so uh so yeah so
she I mean she doesn't create a literal
light obviously I guess it's a
figurative light which you know again
convenient so she does that and
apparently one of the guests of the
ghost is like um oh okay thanks ma'am
and just like walks through and I was
like what okay that was easy like I
didn't even [__] see a light or
anything
now Karen says to Lynn though well there
is one more ghost in the building but I
don't think this one is Sinister this is
the one that's like been quiet or
whatever so I don't think you'll have
any more problems so you know just kind
of like live with it or whatever
so they said no weird [__] happened for
the next three days like after Karen
made the light for the ghost to
disappear into seriously I really want
to know I wish you'd have like said how
she did it she didn't like she just said
it like it was something she did every
[__] day it's just like it was just
really weird to me so uh so yeah
but three days later like after it being
quiet Lynn is closing up with one of the
bartenders
and a martini glass
um comes flying off a shelf and like
smashes into the bartender's hand and
like cuts it
and the bartender also says that she
sees Jason like in a mirror that's in
the um the bar like across the bar like
in the restaurant even though Jason is
not there like he's already gone home
for the night so but she's like I just
saw him like in the mirror you know what
I mean
so uh so yeah
Lynn uh then invites some of her friends
over because they said well she doesn't
really you know she owns a bar in a
restaurant now so she doesn't really
have a social life anymore so
she invites like three or four of her
girlfriends over for to kind of like
hang out and have dinner and stuff like
that in the restaurant
and while they're all sitting around
shooting the [__]
um her necklace which I think was the
Saint Christopher medal it um kind of
pulls up by itself and like starts
choking her so it like pulls like way
back like like that and she essentially
just like falls down on the floor like
she's choking to death and all the other
women are like what the [__] are you
doing
I thought it was so funny they were just
like so like not sympathetic at first
they said what are you doing even though
it's clear that the necklace is like
coming up by itself and she's like I'm
obviously not doing anything um please
help me but so yeah so she kind of like
falls on the floor and I guess like the
Saint Christopher medal like comes off
like it's pulled off her
um so yeah it turns out
that I guess the ghost that Karen sent
into the light or whatever uh was not
the [__] the one that remains is the
[__] so you know there's there's a
plot twist right there
so they said over the next few days uh
the the place became really oppressive
and like feeling really dangerous you
know what I mean
so one afternoon they said it was really
busy like a lot more busy than usual for
this time of day
and Lynn this was really weird Lynn said
she started but again subjective she
started hearing everyone's thoughts
like she's standing in the bar and she
all of a sudden heard all of these
voices in her head and they were all
talking about her but they were all
saying really negative [__] like what
the [__] is this drink this [__] made
me and it's like what if she doesn't
know what she's doing and all this other
kind of [__] so like everybody was like
talking smack about her and
um like it like in her head you know
what I mean
um but she said there was 57 people in
there because she specifically said
there was 57 people Canada like thinking
shitty stuff about her just like the
kids yeah it was the 57 varieties
varieties yeah 27 varieties of people
thinking shitty things about her you
know what I mean so yeah so that was
like kind of a weird and I was like
[__] I I kind of feel like if that
happened to me just suddenly like that I
think I'd be going to a shrink because
that's that sounds like schizophrenia or
something like that right there but uh
yeah if you and and especially because
if you think because I'm sure 57 people
are not all talking about you like get
the [__] over yourself but you know what
I mean it's like she just started
thinking yeah she was having like an
attack of paranoia I guess but applies
plausible maybe like you said you're in
a bad house or you got an evil [__]
Vibe it causes you to fold in on
yourself and you think everybody's after
you you know but you know just give it
but it also just could have been stress
panic yeah you're not in control so yeah
I'm not entirely sure this was a
paranormal why not have been paranormal
might have been a a psychological
repercussions of the stress may be
caused by a paranormal event maybe well
and by the stress of like running the
restaurants too like on top of it all
that [__] happening at once yeah right
it's like a [__] on her is just that
may have not have been paranormal right
yeah I'm not saying it didn't happen to
her I'm just saying that that might not
have been paranormal that might have
just been her being stressed out which
like I said I mean understandably she's
very stressed out
um yeah and at this point this was like
her Breaking Point she just like can't
take anymore she's like [__] this and
she just like runs in the back room and
starts crying and freaking out and Jason
comes back there to see what's the
matter with her and he apparently
think something like she can hear it he
thinks something and it's like man we
are not going to the hospital this is
like so embarrassing or something like
that like he thinks that and she like
looks at him like [__] looks daggers
at the [__] and he's like uh
what and she's you know and she's and
she repeats like what he apparently was
thinking and they didn't specify like if
he was like holy [__] that really was
what I was thinking he didn't say that
um but he just kind of stands there
going uh and she's like I heard you you
know what I mean so I don't know if he
really was thinking that because you'd
think that he would have said holy [__]
she said exactly what I was thinking
yeah you know what I mean but he didn't
say that so maybe she was just imagining
Pookie's being all lovey
want to come up and do that don't pull
me no don't pull me
she's like yeah okay yeah she's being
good she's yeah mostly she's a little
bratty but that's okay
um so yeah at this point Jason's like
okay you really need a break because
you're clearly having like a nervous
breakdown
so she actually takes a few days off
like and stays home for a few days and
Jason's like you know I Pro I think we
should probably sell this place I mean
it's stressing you out it's just like
not worth it
um but Lynn is like you know we've
worked so hard I don't really want to
get rid of it so she ends up going to
yet another psychic holy crap how many
psychics does she know I don't know but
so she goes to this other psychic whose
name is Pam faith I think they said what
is what her name was
and she actually goes to Pam's place to
talk to her but Pam's like no she's like
I know that the bar is your problem so I
want to go there
so she wants to come to the bar
and she's like I'm gonna come here and
you know uh release your bad spirits and
implies Loki that maybe there's some
demons because you know some demons had
to get involved at some point it can't
just be ghosts you know what I mean
so Pam comes in and she basically says
well you got lots and lots of spirits in
here
um and there's an entity in the basement
which is guess what demonic yeah because
you know you had to have one you know
they're gonna be demonic Boogie why is
your head so little
[Laughter]
it's so round yeah yeah you got a little
round head yeah look at her little chill
face yeah she chills she's like she's
like I'm on TV
look at that TV yeah
John Gore said I was having a nervous
breakdown looking for a camera charger
for over an hour it was literally in an
ice bucket that was right in front of me
I have that [__] happen all the time
where the [__] is this I just had it and
then I'm like oh yeah it's right there
okay
I'm fine
all right
so um so Pam basically says I'm gonna go
down to the basement and like confront
the Demonic entity you know what I mean
you stay here in constant prayer that's
what that's what she says to win so Lynn
just stays up there she does exactly
what she's told she stays up there just
like praise over and over and over so
Pam goes down to the basement to you
know confront the demon and kick his ass
out or whatever
um you know telling God get rid of this
demon and all that other kind of [__]
and uh so at this point there's like
seems like there's a lot of Shadows
floating around uh some Phantom wind
they throw that in there like some light
swinging around that kind of [__] you
know to kind of make it look more
dramatic
and so apparently there really there
wasn't a lot there wasn't like a big
climax Pam just basically goes down in
the basement and walks around and says
hey God get rid of the demon and then
all of a sudden she's like oh we felt
the energy shift and the demon was gone
and I was like yeah
that was it you just asked God and there
it is that was some whippy-ass Demon
yeah he's just oh okay normally they
fight back that's what I'm saying they
have a whole priest and everything a
whole priest he's got a whole not a half
just the bottom half of the race that's
gonna show up think about that boo
bottom half of a priest
yeah she's like I don't know
okay yeah oh I'm baby talking to the
kitty we always do that's how that's how
she knows we're talking to her yeah
that's the Pookie voice yeah
but yeah I don't know I thought it was a
good episode it is a good episode yeah
but I just thought like the end was a
little anticlimactic because it's it
wasn't like and I know it's like that's
kind of like hypocritical of me because
I usually kind of like [__] on the ones
that have like a big Exorcism of a thing
because I'm like ooh they're like waving
the camera around and like flashing
lights and it's like nobody said they
saw that come on this one though it just
seemed like oh it's a demon all of a
sudden and then the psychic goes down in
the basement and wanders around and then
all of a sudden woo it's gone yeah and I
was like she didn't even like throw salt
at it or yeah do any kind of like big
hosannas or anything she didn't do
anything like that the strong part about
this case is that there are there were
there were many witnesses there were a
lot yeah uh what they reported was
interesting
not super impressive but it's
interesting that so many people had
little experiences in there
it might have been a bad place you know
what I mean
um but a lot of the other stuff there's
no way to prove it or disprove it you
just go with what they said you know I
mean yeah I felt the energy shift and
it's gone now
yeah because apparently that's the like
the psychic comes back up from the
basement and Lynn knew immediately oh
the Demon's gone like she could feel it
you know what I mean but see like I said
the subjective stuff is not
but this one did have a lot of kind of
like Poltergeist type activity with like
[__] flying around and stuff right which
that to me is like a lot more
interesting because at least like
multiple people could see that I've
never seen anything exactly like this
personally
but in my experience with having a
poltergeist case and being in a bad
house another time
I can imagine that
probably what it was is it was uh like
like a bad place
there was some Poltergeist type
phenomena there I would call probably
like mild haunting
I probably wouldn't would have been kind
of like impressed if I saw it it's like
yeah okay this is the real thing
but it wasn't impressive as a
poltergeist case that I was involved in
a lot more [__] was moving but you know
this this
people that have never seen anything
like that it would have wigged them out
and all this other super all this stuff
around the uh the edges of you know
demons and oh it went away that was
their perception of it
might still be there it might just be a
kind of a small disturbance of some sort
it's weird there's no way of knowing
because they did say they did say at the
end that they were kind of like well it
seemed like the Paranormal Activity
stopped after that but you know they
always kind of like leave it open like
oh but maybe it'll come back you know
because they still got that mirror in
there that's what I would think if it
was there it's probably still there it'd
probably just for some reason or another
kind of went more dormant
there's just no way no way to explain
why
you'd have to [__] actually project
let's see and go into the [__] Astro
realm and go to that area and see what
it is
if it's still there or not to really
know and then when you came back people
would really really wouldn't believe
what you saw
just like people don't realize that
[__] Reverend hung sung Moon
destroyed communism
himself by going astral sure yeah
that's the nice thing about saying that
is
you could say you did anything yeah yeah
I was like well yeah but you wouldn't
know about it because I was in the
astral plane you don't know anything
about it he went Moon Reverend Moon went
into the astral Prime and fixed it
communism is gone that's a wrap it's
going to take time I worked that out I
worked it out I
started
I've heard something anytime
he just says it's like oh my God thank
God they solved that that was me I don't
know if you know I I went astral and
solved that [__] you're welcome
[Laughter]
but you know laughing and joking uh I
had that happen to me it was spontaneous
I didn't try to do it just did it
the barracks that I was in the Army and
I had a near-death experience that
shit's real I don't uh it's hard near
impossible to want to do it
it's something that kind of just happens
trying to do it foils it
you have to kind of just give up the
ghost you have to like it's like a
willing to willing yourself to die is
what it feels like
it is a real Zone
now do I think you can go over there and
fix communism no no
no
not at all
can you go over there and fix other
things probably seemed like it you can
interact with things the thing is though
is that you change when you when you
exteriorize
you go out and you go oh yeah communism
yeah there's a certain Zen in allowing
things to remain [__] up I'm Gonna
Leave communism that's the way you would
that's that's the way you that's the
that's the plan for the universe you
know that's how you that's how you would
proceed so you just go to the astral
plane and become a bum that doesn't
you're kind of like a bum
I'm just gonna lay here on the couch
metaphorically and just do anything yeah
that's good it's supposed to be like
that just let that go yeah I could fix
it but yeah you could fix it though
that's so funny that was like that would
actually make a good short story it
could go into the astral plane and fix
it yeah yeah look how [__] that up
that's [__] up that is you know what
[__] it I'm just gonna love you I'm just
gonna leave it
yeah I'm gonna experience the Zen of
just leaving it like that
but there's a fine line between leaving
[__] then and just being lazy yeah you
know what I mean that's a very fine line
I'm just predicting how it would go from
your point of view it'd be like that
I didn't go look at communism
I wasn't worried about that
look at communism God damn
how do I fix this where's moon at no
he's probably over here right yeah
over here bro
check it out I don't speak Hangul all
right keep your ass over in Korea but
let's look at this [__] together
we fixed this [__] South Korea will
be set Bro how do we stop
foreign
[Laughter]
just let it be
oh my God this is a hilarious discussion
all right so I guess if we better start
wrapping it up because it's almost nine
o'clock and uh I can take a shower and
we have to watch the end of remember we
were doing the review yesterday of
um
Leon the Professional and we mentioned
the movie Gloria so we actually found it
on Amazon Prime yeah 3.99 for 3.99 so
halfway through it it's a long movie we
started watching it last night but I
couldn't stay awake I kept I kept like
dozing off and then Tom kept going hey
and I was like Hey God damn it I was
like it's a good movie it's better than
I remembered it it is it's really good
yeah it's really good well I didn't
realize but um the main actress what's
her [__] name God damn it it's just I
had it and they're a friend Angel she
does a bit yeah
um I can't remember but I think she was
nominated for an Oscar the Year this
came out I think he came out in 1980.
and somebody said it got remade too like
with Sharon Stone and it is like the
professional the plot is very similar
like it's not exactly the same and the
little bud loves her but the setup is
very very similar very similar yeah the
little boy loves her thinks that she
thinks that he thinks that she's his
girlfriend that little kid's a [__]
yeah he's a trip Tom said he looks very
difficult woman Thompson it's like look
he looks like a tiny Art Garfunkel
forehead and everything you got a six
head and he's got like a
[Music]
The Sound of Silence that's a good song
hello darkness my old friend
I like soccer yeah we're good
Zach says Natalie Portman yeah she
wasn't Leon the Professional we talked
about it yesterday I don't think you
were here though was Zach not here
yesterday uh yeah I guess he wasn't yeah
we talked about that maybe yesterday and
then we brought up the movie Gloria
which is because Tom remembered it being
it's from 1980 but it's very very
similar the plot is very similar yeah
it's just gender swapped
pretty much yeah it's like an older
woman although it's I can't like I said
I can't what is her [__] name that's
in it it's right in the tip of my tongue
um and you said well oh she's not as old
as I remembered her being because
because you described it as her being
like an old white haired and she's maybe
50. she's maybe 50 yeah right I remember
Gina Rollins thank you yeah I remember
there being more like 60. yeah but no
but she's it yeah she's not she's not
that old but she's has our remembered
her
tough gangster broad yeah
she was a gangster mistress
she's super funny like at the beginning
like when they were trying to pawn the
kid off she's like I hate kids and I
specifically hate your kids
and I was like yeah I feel that she has
some gangster skills too there's guys
pulled up to try to abduct that kid so
they could kill him he had the book and
just without warning she opened fires on
the car the car is [__] running away
and [__] roll they roll a car yeah
cause I'm watching that and I was like
holy [__] I was like yeah I weren't
expecting that were you I was like yeah
yeah
Quick Draw that [__] sick little five
shot [__] 38 Special she had I was
like damn you know yeah
later on she's [__] taking guns from
gangsters
took a lot of gangsters guns from him
took their ammo left gave them the guns
back on one yeah zero tried to shoot me
with a magnum she [__] took that
three to seven Magnum snub nose she's
got that now too
that's about when that's about where we
left off yeah we made it very realistic
we might have to back it up a few
minutes yeah because I think I fell
asleep yeah it's a very realistic movie
um
it's not like over-the-top action or
anything it's
kind of like how [__] goes in certain
ways
yeah Zach says uh she was Oscar
nominated for that movie while the kid
was Razzie nominated really he was he's
not bad
he's well I was I yeah I mean I was
thinking while I was watching it like
his character is hilarious because like
some of the [__] that he says is really
funny yeah but you can tell at every
moment that he's acting yeah like he
doesn't yeah he's not an actor no
he's just a kid in a movie yeah that's
clearly trying to act yeah you know what
I mean so but he's young he's six I
think yeah well he's supposed to be six
he looks a little bit older but I'm not
good at like judging kids ages you know
what I mean I think he's about six but
yeah that's how old he's supposed to be
all right so we are gonna wrap it up for
the evening uh so Wednesday night is the
main show as you guys know and I'm very
excited because we are going to be doing
the show on Vincent Price I'm so jazzed
that was what won in the poll so it's I
thought it was about time to cover
Vincent Price because we already did
Christopher Lee and Peter Cushing and
Bella Lugosi and Boris Karloff and
Vincent Price got kind of left out now
we'll have to do a show about basil
Rathbone too I guess well or like Lon
Chaney where it is never like opening up
a whole can of worms but yeah we're
totally doing a show about Vincent Price
on Wednesday night so that should be
super super fun so watch some Vincent
Price movies in preparation
and we'll talk about that on Wednesday
but yeah thanks everybody for dropping
by and thanks for super chats and all of
that remember to like and do all that
kind of stuff I always forget to say
that oh and also I put up two videos
over the weekend if you didn't see them
I put up a book review and I put up um
something over on scare Salon where I'm
doing the Boris Karloff Thriller series
like I did the last five episodes of
season one so if you didn't see that
then it's like an hour long so go check
it out so yeah we'll see you guys again
on Wednesday night good